I'm convinced because I can't imagine
how it could have happened any other way
that language is a lot older than
meaning surely that must be so that we
discovered long before we discovered
rational
conversation we discovered that we could
play with our mouths and make funny
noises for each other's Amusement we
still do this with scat singing and
glossolalia and nonsense Rhymes and this
sort of thing and strangely meaning it
hears
where definition is absent there is
still meaning
it was brilliant
and the sly the toes did gyre and
Invincible in the wave all menacing
and the money rats upgrade
beware the jabberwock my son the Jaws
that bite the claws the catch beware the
job job birds and shunned the firmiest
band of snatch
he took his thoughtful sword in hand
long time the maximum foe he sought so
rested he by the tum tum tree and stood
a while in thought
and as you know fish thought he stood
the jabberwock with eyes of flame came
whiffing through the touchy wood and
bubbled as it came
one two one two and through and through
his vocal blade when Snicker smacked
he left it dead and with his head he
went the lump thing back
and as thou slaying the jabberwock
come to my arms my Danish boy oh
frumptious day
he chuckled in his Joy it was brilliant
and the sly they told us desire and
gimbal in the wave all Mimsy were the
butterballs and the money wrath South
Gray
so there you have it
probably just evocative what we sense we
later are able to
analytically communicate but the sound
there in Jabberwocky it's the sound
which carries it and I'm convinced that
for a long long time people amused each
other in that fashion and in more
radical Fashions with complete nonsense
syllables and it was only some late
arriving very nerdish and practical type
who said you know what we could do with
this stuff
[Music]
foreign
[Music]